pamela tips on pitching whether it be
pitch vests or for other avenues what
you need to do when you're pitching is
do what every story needs and that is to
give us someone or something to be
sympathetic to give us some danger and
give us some kind of salvation or
resolution I like to just use the
initials SDS sympathy danger salvation
so in your first sentence tell us who
the character is and why we would want
to go on this journey with them even if
we don't like them we don't like them
but to be sympathetic to engage with
them so establish the sympathy then
what's the danger what's the problem are
they fighting the world are they
fighting a fear of heights do they want
children but they can't because it's
maybe a society that doesn't allow them
anymore you whatever it is give us the
danger and then give us the salvation or
the resolution now we said well it's not
salvation because they don't win well
that's all right all the Greek tragedies
taught us something so even if your
character doesn't save the day and
doesn't win we still want to know what
victory would have looked like because
that makes it all the sadder that they
don't make it so
sympathy danger salvation
you